vsauce kevin here kevin lieber actually
that's my name it's german but i'm not
the only one there are 10 other kevin
liebers in the united states so what if
one of the other kevin lieber's is
connected to a murder of another
youtuber three miles from right here and
the only surviving victim identified me
kevin lieber as the killer to top it all
off mr beast testified that i confessed
to this murder to him
and i'm the only one who knows
i'm innocent
all of this actually happened not to me
to a woman named joyce ann brown
[Music]
[Music]
they needed a conviction they needed the
pressure off two blacks in dallas texas
in texas period walked in and brought
open daylight shot and killed a
businessman
somebody was gonna pay i'm there
somebody on thursday may 8 1980 the
dallas morning news published a short
article buried in the paper's local news
section a shop called fine furs by ruben
had been robbed and its owner ruben
danziger was murdered his wife allah
said reuben pleaded don't hurt me
don't hurt me before one of two female
robbers
shot him in the head
allah escaped by telling them she had
terminal cancer with just weeks to live
one of the women said
we'll just let you suffer
and left as police looked for suspects
they found the getaway car a dachshund
rented to a woman named joyce ann brown
a police officer recognized the name as
someone who'd been arrested years prior
for a minor sex work charge so they
asked publicly for joyce and brown to
come in for questioning
joyce immediately went into the police
station to clear up the confusion
she wasn't worried she knew she didn't
do it and she had an alibi she was at
work when the crime occurred
and
this is where the incredible
coincidences
really begin
joyce worked at coslos another first
store just across town so she'd
presumably know which valuable furs to
steal
working nearby in the fur industry with
the same first middle and last name as
the getaway cars renter quite a
coincidence but even so joyce denied any
involvement the interrogator told her
you're lying we know you pulled that
robbery
so she was arrested and held on one
million dollar bail then police realized
that the joyce ann brown who rented the
car
actually lived in denver colorado she
was a completely different person in a
completely different state and that
joyce said that she lent the car to a
friend but by then it was too late
joyce's mug shot from her prior arrest
had been shown in a lineup to mrs
danziger who identified her as one of
the robbers and she said that that woman
had been in the store to case it out in
the weeks leading up to the crime forget
relying just on a weird name thing now
the police had an eyewitness
identification
okay but what about joyce's solid work
alibi there was about a seven minute
window that would have allowed joyce to
commit the robbery leave the scene
change her clothes drive back to work
and compose herself as if nothing was
out of the ordinary before talking to a
co-worker at 1 19 p.m
and the police said
that must be exactly what happened but
what actually happened we'll get to that
in one second real quick this video is
sponsored by keeps two out of three
66.66 repeating percent this isn't the
monty hall paradox this is the ratio of
guys who will experience some form of
male pattern baldness before they're 35
well it's easier and more affordable to
prevent hair loss with keeps just go
online and talk to an actual doctor who
will ship you medication every three
months and it's the generic versions of
the only two fda approved medications
for preventing hair loss treatments
typically take between four to six
months to start seeing results so the
sooner you start the sooner you'll save
your luscious man locks to take action
and prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
vsauce2 or click the link in the
description to get 50 off your first
order that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com vsauce2 all right so none of the
items recovered from police searches the
rental car joyce's apartment linked her
to the crime but when evidence starts to
suggest that weird things are
coincidences it's tempting to just come
up with new evidence suddenly a woman
named martha jean bruce claimed that
joyce had confessed to her while they
shared a jail cell after joyce's arrest
bruce said there was no incentive for
her to testify to that but remarkably a
few months later the d.a recommended
that bruce be released over three years
early on a five-year attempted murder
sentence
so
yeah the da's investigator adi christian
found her story convincing after i
talked to her a little bit in detail she
began to tell me some things that
indicated to me that she would have had
to talk to someone involved in that
crime if because of the facts that she
had about the way the furs was
supposedly uh baggage when the when they
left the scene and martha jean bruce had
that information she knew that they were
in plastic bags but she could have read
that in the newspapers oh and
martha jean bruce had already been
convicted of lying to police but the
prosecutors ignored that the odds of it
all being the universe's cruel joke
against joyce and brown were just too
much for the jury she was found guilty
and sentenced and there was no hope that
calculus was ever going to be in her
favor
everything added up for the prosecution
and the pattern checked out their case
went like this joyce ann brown is the
black former prostitute in texas accused
of involvement in the robbery and murder
of a holocaust survivor on her lunch
break from work at the same type of
store a few miles away with the
surviving victim visually identifying
her sworn testimony of a jailhouse
confession and the getaway car rented in
her exact name
here's a question
what are the odds someone with
your name commits a crime
since there are only 10 other kevin
lieber's i'm pretty safe but what if
your name is
michael stevens
there are 2
975
total michael stevenses in the united
states how about john smith he's got 48
439 other potential criminal john smiths
conversely
tanner butts in a sense is
firmly up to him
six months after joyce's conviction the
other woman linked to the robbery and
murder was finally apprehended renee
taylor police found furs and the murder
weapon in her apartment she told police
that she had no idea who joyce ann brown
was but she refused to give up the name
of her actual accomplice because she
didn't want to ruin that woman's life
renee taylor was convicted of murder and
sent to the mountain view maximum
security prison where she served time
with
joyce and brown
guards were ordered to keep the two
women apart
joyce is in prison renee taylor is in
prison but it took years to determine
who renee's real accomplice was
a woman named lorraine germany who'd
also robbed an albuquerque new mexico
fur store with taylor and an
investigator told joyce that lorraine
looked enough like you
to be your twin sister
name
furs doppelganger ridiculous
in 1984 joyce's appeal was denied on her
birthday two weeks later
her son shot himself his last words to
her were
mama when are they gonna let you out we
don't have a family anymore
most crimes aren't all that different
from each other and the details usually
add up there are often familiar patterns
the dallas police fell victim to the
ange to lung effect a cognitive
phenomenon detailed in my video can
learning make you dumb
they had tunnel vision based on their
experience they also had a lot of
possible evidence to choose from so they
only saw what they wanted to see
and they wanted to see it in a certain
way it's the same mistake we saw with
brandon mayfield's fingerprint case and
just like sally clark's trial the
prosecution and jury refused to admit
that long odds and crazy coincidences
really do
happen they just do or maybe they just
didn't understand that they do
one way to combat the einstein effect is
to bring in people to look at the
problem who aren't used to operating in
familiar patterns
dallas morning news journalists steve
mcgonigal and steve blow started
questioning the district attorney's
narrative
jim mccloskey of centurion ministries in
princeton new jersey and his own
investigator started putting the
evidence together to get joyce
exonerated and in 1989 just weeks after
morley safer of 60 minutes aired a
14-minute piece detailing the doubt
surrounding joyce's conviction she was
finally granted a re-trial for the first
time in
nine years five months and 24 days
joyce was free and months later the d.a
dropped the case against her
joyce ann brown spent the years
following her release working as an
assistant to a county official before
founding an organization to assist the
incarcerated and their families
she died of a heart attack in 2015.
joyce's strength and character allowed
her to turn her injustice
into a springboard to help other people
but she never should have had to do that
in the first place joyce wrote in her
book justice denied that she had faith
in the system
if you did a crime you did the time if
you were innocent you went free
the thing is
lives like joyce and browns have been
and will continue to be destroyed
because we keep getting the same things
wrong
we fall prey to the same cognitive
biases
analytical fallacies and just plain
thinking errors that i've been exploring
on this channel for years
one day it's the einstein effect the
next day it's confirmation bias or any
of dozens of misinterpretations
in math
i know all of these things you know all
of these things but not everyone else
does and their compounding errors can
determine the freedom of people named
well
whatever your
first middle and
last name is
and as always
thanks for watching
well the first thing i'm going to do is
spend some time with my daughter
and that very night i'm going to sleep
in the bed with my mama
i've been waiting on that day a long
time
[Music]
[Music]
you